why would an artist need a coach I think
every person but especially in Artistry
where you're trying to express something
to connect with an audience uh it comes
from a deep knowing and understanding of
yourself and your voice and it comes
from a foundation of what you value what
you love and what you trust I think that
when we connect to Art whatever form
that is in we're connecting to the
expression of that whether it's in a
painting or we at Rock show or even in a
movie and when you partner with a coach
a really excellent coach someone who is
really guiding you towards your answers
not someone who's giving you the answers
or telling you what path to walk someone
who's bringing you within and helping
you build that strong internal
Foundation you take that everywhere you
go and especially on the creative path
there is no one path the creative path
is the process of us consistently and
continually finding ourselves and
integrating that into who we are and how
we want to express that I think artists
need I don't think they just have the
option to I think I believe that every
artist needs to at some point find the
kind of partnership whether it's through
coaching or otherwise that brings them
back into themselves back grounding to
their purpose of what am I here to do
because we're they're gifted we're
gifted with the ability to create or the
vision that we have for a creation or
piece of art a piece of work and to
almost have the skill to clear that
channel and move almost your humanness
out of the way to let that message come
through you is
essential and I think in a really
healthy coaching partnership we can
create that space that's really what I
mean when I say coming home to yourself
is uh creating that space and having
that um that clearing to be able to
access what that message is what that
gift is to express it what if someone
has too much pride to seek out a
coach that's real that's just the path
they're on I've in the beginning of my
coaching career have tried to work with
people or try to meet with people who
kind of you might describe them as
having uh being prideful and not
thinking they need the help or even
categorizing or thinking of coaching as
kind of something where
um in a more negative light like oh
people who are really struggling or
really need help like PE PE maybe it's a
weakness that you need to partner with a
coach that's actually quite a common
thought I think still coaching is is has
been around for a long time but I think
it still has a confusing reputation to
many people in the mainstream but if
people have too much pride to partner
with a coach this is not their Journey
right now and that's okay too and in
fact before coaching I came from working
with some a-level celebrities and I
worked in the industry for years and I
faced a lot of that when I started to
talk about the training I was doing and
the career path I was starting to step
on
um
and it took me a while to get out of my
own way and my own pride and H and
integrate the fact that I am a trained
coach just for those same reasons of
like what are people going to think and
what do I think of this but in reality I
so believe in the work I do and in the
result that I see my clients move
through and how I myself have moved
through my art and my creative process
that that has just become so much more
important than any type of e sense of
ego Pride that I need to hold on to and
by the way there's nothing wrong with
ego we need it to survive like we need
it to navigate as social beings so I'm
not like bashing ego but at the end of
the day we can't live in our ego it's a
tool more than it is an
identity what if someone has too much
shame to seek out a coach maybe there's
things in their past they're embarrassed
about or family conditioning you don't
need to go to someone you don't need to
talk about things often time our shame
eets Us Alive and our shame lives in we
all live in it lives in thoughts or
sentences like oh I should do that or I
should you know the shoulds when we
should on each other and in my
experience with people who hold a lot of
that who are holding on to a lot of
those stories and a lot of that shame
sometimes it's a different healing
modality that they need to step into
before they're ready to work with a
coach because coaching um is really
different from other types of healing
for example therapy this is a question I
get a lot how is coaching different from
therapy well uh the result of therapy is
Insight whereas the result of coaching
is always action and we're not asking
the question why in coaching why is
irrelevant in this space and it happened
because it happened and I'm sure there's
a story attached to it and I'm I'm sure
it's true it probably happened to you
yet what's more important in this space
of coaching is what is it that I'm doing
or seeing or what are my patterns and
what do I want to do about
it specifically in conjunction to where
do I want to be and when we ask what it
becomes a much more interesting question
and I'm not to say not to say why is not
good worth you to explore back to your
question when we have our carrying a lot
of Shame the why is the important
question we have to develop a sense of
awareness around ourselves and an
internal processing system and that's
better done through therapy or other
healing modalities whether it's breath
work or yoga or you know what choose
your adventure um and i' and I've
dabbled in a
lot but coaching is really for people
who are at a developed level of
awareness where they're self they're
aware enough that whatever story it is
they're carrying or holding on to is
less relevant and important than the
vision that they have and they want to
move
toward that's the point where you me a
coach what is it about you that makes
you want to be a
coach what is it about me that makes me
want to be a
coach there's an art to connecting with
people there's an art to this process to
finding and establishing your creative
process
there's an art to the intention that
comes with it and I'm I'm addicted to
that art simply
put when I worked for highlevel
composers this who I mentioned earlier I
saw how I served a specific A-list
composer and I was his personal
assistant and by his side and got to
observe how he was with music and at
times he was music when I talk about
artists are a channel for their work I
mean he was like a human sacrifice for
his music at times for it to flow
through him and he is exquisite at what
he does and it was in incredibly
inspiring and I I think I saw that and I
was able to like connect to him in that
way not because I'm a musician in the
same way but because I feel like I am
gifted in a way to connect with people
and to find a channel for that and a way
to express that and to make a
contribution with that um is the job is
my work is what I need to to do to
connect and so you know just seeing that
person be it so excellently and so high
level and I just mean he's been doing it
his whole life I realize I've been doing
this my whole life I have always been
this way I've always been ready to
connect I have always been the person my
friends will come to my family will come
to not so much for advice that too but
also just a safe place a safe place to
be um and to be authentic in who they
are with me and that is something I
value so highly so to channel that and
hone it into a craft into um a skill set
is is the gift of finding coaching and
finding this type of format and may it
may evolve it's already been evolving as
I've been walking this path it might be
a different job title it might be
applied a different way but to be on the
path of honing that gift and craft um is
essential to take those first few steps
why do you specifically coach artists
and other
creatives um because I am obsessed with
them because I am one and my mom was an
artist and my dad is a high level
creative he he's a he's a financial
strategist and I've never seen anyone
more creative I mean it really has
nothing to do with the job if you know
what I'm saying it's a type of person
that I'm drawn to and that I am and that
I think we all are intrinsically
creative this is The Human Condition
some of us are more called to express
that on a professional level or as a
lifestyle and I'm really drawn to it and
I'm drawn to working with artists and
creatives because I'm drawn
to I'm drawn to the
unknown the mystery of
life changing things up we never know
there's no such life is not linear our
brain wants to think in a linear way
it's so comforting to be linear it's
it's it's how we're wired and it's so
not what's real life is more if we're to
use a shape cyclical everything circles
back everything comes back at a deeper
level in a different way with different
meaning and so to follow along that
story with the artists that I get to
meet and to to be kind of part of their
Journey for a part of their path you
know what I'm saying to be on their team
for a part of that process for them it's
like an
addiction it's an addiction to the
process
I've learned so much about myself and my
own creative application through the
conversations I've had with my
clients yeah I've heard even uh you know
because you can apply really creativity
to so many jobs that you wouldn't think
are quote creative and when you talked
about money and finance I've heard
people saying about you know certain
patterns of a stock the way they rise
and fall I don't know if it's called
like the Fibonacci sequence or something
and that there's like a pattern and a
rhythm a beauty to it then he would
never to me I would be like okay you I
don't really understand it but yeah
maybe you don't understand the stock
Rhythm but you understand the Rhythm in
the way that you see it it's like that
scene from American Beauty where the
plastic bag is flying in the wind and
it's like have you ever seen anything
more beautiful and to some people that's
hilarious and they're like what a dumb
movie and to some people they're crying
and they're like I see the beauty it's
like isn't that so cool like but that
plastic bag is the same as a stock
market for someone and it's the same as
a well-written song for someone that's
just what it is and to see that through
other people's perspectives that's what
I say I'm addicted to to see it how they
that's one of my coaching questions is
people bring in metaphors we all speak
in metaphors all the time and part of
what I do with my clients and behind the
scenes info here is to dismantle these
metaphors what are you actually talking
about what are you seeing or what are we
not seeing and so when we get to strip
away the metaphor and really hear what
their voice of wisdom is saying I mean
that's like some pure energy right there
that's something very pure and very
special and very that's what makes them
the artist that they are a lot of people
come to me like well yeah but
rationalizing there's a billion singers
in the world what makes me any different
why should I pursue this art it's like
they're not a billion use let's get you
to that
core what are some of the metaphors like
do you hear certain ones that you can
tell are are blocks and others that that
are freeing yeah some of the metaphors
and this will probably be familiar you
to you as well and I I say this all the
time will'll just be like you know part
of me didn't want to call her back but
the other part of me thought we are not
parts of self we are one whole being we
are one whole unit and that's such an
interesting metaphor that I'm really
deepening right now in my practice
because when we speak about parts of our
self um that's a lot of
information there's a lot of information
that we do and that's kind of the first
step of my process with people is to
bring all our parts together because we
need to have the whole team on Deck the
whole team meaning all parts of oursel
and when I say that's a lot of
information it's like uh so often we
want to block parts that are speaking to
us or we want to not hear those things
and it may be too painful to hear what
they're serving up but the more we are
able to assert our focus and attention
to what it is is coming up for us and
actually integrate that there's a
process to that the more whole we will
start to feel and move forward in our
life or our craft or whatever it is with
a sense of wholeness and
belonging it's an internal job but it
really helps to have someone hear that
and go wait a minute well what what do
you mean by part of you and let's
dismantle that what is it saying without
shame or judgment let's observe what's
coming up for you observation means
without judgment to look at it and
that's when it starts to become
interesting cuz we're no longer
interested in like this is a bad part of
me this is good whatever what does that
even mean we're more interested in what
is coming up that I need to focus on and
potentially integrate into my
practice